Speaker 1: All right, folks, this is beyond
parody. We now have pictures of Trump's toilet
with the flushed documents. It's beyond belief.
You might remember that during his presidency,
Donald Trump was obsessed with toilets. The
only president I can remember this fixated
on what we call the third element of the bathroom.
Remember this viral moment with Trump and toilets?
Speaker 3: We have a situation where we're
looking very strongly at sinks and showers.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 3: And other elements of bathrooms
where you turn the faucet on in areas
where there's tremendous amounts of water,
where the water rushes out to sea
because everywhere never handle it.
And you don't get any water. You turn
on the faucet, you don't get any water.
They take a shower and water comes
dripping out. Is creeping out very quietly.
Speaker 1: Quietly wet, quiet water.
That's not that. You're not getting
the water pressure you need there.
Speaker 3: Now, people are flushing
toilets ten times. 15 times as opposed to one.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And when this this was so
bizarre. And then we learned that Donald Trump
would regularly flush documents down the toilet in
direct contravention to the Presidential Records
Act. He would just flush them. And then I realized
this is why Trump was so concerned with the third
element of the bathroom. Well, Trump denied that
he was doing that. And now we have the pictures
exclusive. This is the first time on this program
I have ever brought to you pictures of a toilet.
But here are pictures that Axios was able to
obtain. And you see a piece of paper in the
toilet. It says Rogers, it says Stefanik. Elise
Stefanik is a Republican congresswoman. We have
it. And Axios reports remember our toilet scoop.
Earlier this year, Maggie Haberman, a forthcoming
book about Trump, will report that the White House
staff periodically found wads of paper clogging
a toilet and believed Trump was the flusher.
It turns out there are photos published for the
first time. Haberman obtained the photos recently,
shared them with Axios ahead of the release of
her book. A Trump White House source tells her
the photo on the left shows a commode in the White
House. The photo on the right is from an overseas
trip, folks Trump was using for in plumbing
to dispose of these massive dumps of notes.
This is an unbelievable situation. It is 2022
and we now have toilet pictures proving that
Donald Trump was indeed flushing notes down the
toilet, maybe explaining why he was so displeased
with the suction level of the toilets at
the White House. I don't know. I think I
might have to retire. I genuinely don't. What
is the point of me continuing to do the show
after a story like this? But this is where we
are. And as usual, the narrative continues to be.
Story comes out. Trump denies it. Then there are
pictures. Then there's a phone call. Then there's
proof that goes above and beyond. I don't even. I
feel it only diminishes the story if I say more.
It sort of needs to be presented without further
comment type of thing. So I will leave it there.
If you want to see the proof, make sure you're
following us on Instagram at David Pakman show